Дизельні та бензинові машини дедалі більше
пов'язують із забрудненням довкілля та шкодою для здоров'я.
Екологічною альтернативою мають стати електрокари.
Та чи справді вони сприятливіші для довкілля?
Поки що електрокари - аутсайдери.
Нині їх налічується лише близько 5,5 мільйонів у світі.
Це майже ніщо в порівнянні з традиційними автівками
на бензині та дизелі: їх майже 1,5 мільярда.
Найважливіша перевага електромобілів -
вони не спричиняють викидів СО2.
Для сучасних загазованих міст це просто знахідка.
Але опосередковано виробництво електрокарів,
звісно, теж спричиняє викиди вуглекислого газу.
Зате двигун електрокара складається лише з 200 частин,
тоді як двигун внутрішнього згоряння потребує 1200 складових.
А головний екологічний "гріх" електромобілів -
шкідливий для довкілля видобуток літію, кобальту
та рідкісноземельних елементів, необхідних
для серця електрокару - електробатареї.
Окрім того, на родовищах у Південній Америці,
Конго та Китаї часто панують просто нелюдські умови праці.
Добра новина: запасів цих родовищ людству
має вистачити надовго. Згідно з дослідженнями,
світові резерви перевищують дедалі зростаючий попит у кілька разів.
Недолік електромобілів також у тому, що
літій із відпрацьованих акумуляторів
поки що не переробляється. Наразі це доволі
витратний процес і розробники працюють нині
над його оптимізацією. Тоді екологічний баланс
електрокарів значно поліпшиться.
Зрозуміло, що екологічність електрокарів
залежить також і від того, на якому струмі
їздить електромобіль: на "зеленому" струмі
з відновлювальних джерел енергії чи на "брудному"
струмі, скажімо, з теплової електростанції на кам'яному вугіллі.
Значно гальмує розвиток електрокарів
проблема дальності пробігу. На одній зарядці
електромобілі можуть проїхати не більше 400 км.
Також пошук зарядних станцій може перетворитися
на справжню пригоду. До того ж, щоб зарядити
батарею, необхідно щонайменше 40 хвилин.
Питання, звісно ж, також у тому, коли електромобілі
за ціною зможуть сягнути рівня дизельних
чи бензинових автівок. Нині ціни
на нові електрокари все ще дуже високі.
Електромобілі справді безпечніші для довкілля,
аніж машини з двигунами згоряння.
Головна екологічна перевага - відсутність викидів СО2.
Щоправда, екологічний баланс електрокарів
суттєво погіршує виробництво й утилізація батарей.
Нині виробники працюють над тим, як мінімізувати
шкоду для довкілля від літій-іонних акумуляторів,
зокрема піддаючи їх вторинній переробці.
Також екологічність електроавтівки залежить
від виду струму, на якому вона їздить.
Уряди та автовиробники мають робити більше
для того, щоб водіям було вигідно й комфортно
пересідати на електрокари. Лише коли автівки
на струмі стануть масовим явищем, це матиме
позитивний ефект для довкілля.